[Musique]
au coeur de la bretagne à une trentaine
de kilomètres au sud ouest de rennes se
situe la forêt de brocéliande connu
aussi sous le nom de forêt de paimpont
[Musique]
la forêt de brocéliande et le domaine
privilégié des légendes bretonnes et
celtiques brocéliande
c'est bien plus qu'une forêt c'est la
porte ouverte sur une terre d'un autre
monde où règne une atmosphère porteuse
de mystère c'est le musée du imaginaire
en plein air c'est une forêt magique
perdu dans les brumes des chênes
centenaires de nombreux ruisseaux 14
étant des plus impressionnants dès
qu'elle s'échappe l'étonnante histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
brocéliande abrite le monde des dieux
les faits et des esprits quelles que
soient leurs quêtes et leurs croyances
les hommes continuent d'explorer
brocéliande en essayant de renouer un
contact perdu
[Musique]
alors pourquoi venir à brocéliande c'est
une bonne question effectivement parce
qu'on s'aperçoit qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui viennent dans cette
forêt dans cette petite forêt même si
c'est la plus grande des forêts
bretonnes et des gens du monde entier
même qui viennent ici des gens qui
viennent d'amérique latine de russie
deux des états unis de l'europe entière
d'afrique aussi si on prend tout
bêtement une carte en relief de la
bretagne et de la haute bretagne puisque
nous sommes en haute bretagne
il est évident que brocéliande apparaît
pratiquement comme une petite montagne
pour une montagne bien menu en hauteur
mais montagne or le préfixe brocéliande
elle n'est pas semble-t-il à entendre
comme brawl pays
mais comme bret la colline la montagne
et il est évident qu encore aujourd'hui
même dans le système routier par exemple
on voit cette forêt qui est au centre
une espèce de triangle qui n'est pas
franchement sur les routes
et ça pousse à considérer brocéliande
oui comme cette montagne comme quelque
chose d'émerger et d'émerger au milieu
des terres mais d'émerger quand même et
ça ramène à une notion qu'on va
retrouver plus tard au moyen-âge qui la
notion de l'île 2000 et du désert
certains viendront simplement pour
ramasser des champignons dont d'autres
viendront pas sentir les énergie
tellurique qui émane des pierres ou ou
sortir les arts ou d'autres d'audience
pour se promener dont ils ont simplement
pour la poésie pour la littérature c'est
ça qui fait de ce lieu un lieu assez
extraordinaire alors que
spectaculairement on est loin de la tour
eiffel on est loin des architectures
cyclopéenne qu'on peut trouver ailleurs
mais c'est aussi cette spécificité de la
forêt dans notre imaginaire qui est qui
est fort brocéliande c'est aussi un peu
le le dernier refuge
de l'imaginaire le dernier refuge de de
la forêt du petit poucet le dernier
refuge de du loup ah bon c'est une
espèce d'une verte au coeur de la
bretagne et en tant que telle elle
développe une espèce de d'effroi et une
espèce d'attraits dans le même temps
alors dans l'histoire s'en fait un lieu
convoité parce que c'est un lieu de
richesse la forêt est un lieu de
richesses alors la fois de brocéliande
c'est le roi arthur sont les korrigans
ce sont les délais fait mais aussi ce
sont les fantômes de l'impression que
brocéliande un livre magique comme ça
lol quand on parle du dudu du graal il
faut pas oublier que le graal c'est
encore plus ancien en fait c'est c'est
la marmite c'est le sait le sait le
chaudron magique et là on a imposé en
brocéliande c'est un chaudron magique où
peut y puiser et trouver des contes des
légendes c'est inépuisable on on est
dans l'imaginaire et on ressort des
poignets de l'imaginaire de merveilleux
il ya trois portes pour entrer dans le
royaume de brocéliande l'histoire la
légende et le vertige du monde
alors l'histoire bien sûr l'histoire est
très importante ici l'histoire locale
mais aussi l'histoire dont procède en
est un support pour pouvoir parler de
cette histoire l'histoire des celtes
l'histoire de l'année des migrations de
rothen l'histoire du moyen-âge d'ubs au
moyen-âge l'histoire de guillaume le
conquérant l'histoire des plantagenêts
vis-à-vis de légende arthurienne et plus
projet nous l'histoire du développement
du tourisme ici qui est aussi importante
la légende ce patrimoine et matériels
comme on dit maintenant qui est pour
nous une plus belle des plus belles
légendes du monde bien entendu la
légende du roi arthur et de sauver la
table ronde qui a ceci d'extraordinaire
qu'elle est à la fois très ancienne mais
résolument moderne et qui va traverser
les siècles siècle après siècle et faire
l'objet d'une reprise adaptation
incessantes de la part d'un des plus
grands artistes le vertige du monde
c'est pour moi justement cette ce
vertige le fait d'avoir d'être monté
comme ça monte monte en se coupant
peut-être des des anciennes croyances
des anciennes religions l'idée ce n'est
pas peut-être de de croire dur comme fer
à tout ça mais c'est comme don quichotte
quelque part et on est un petit peu des
don quichotte ici c'est de croire qu'on
peut réenchanter le monde
quand le sage montre la lune du doigt
l'homme regarde le bout du doigt elle
n'excède pas à la lune
alors pour moi regarder le bout du doigt
justement c'est ça peut entendre de deux
manières une manière c'est de pas croire
du tout à tout ça et renvoyer tout ça
d'un revers de la main en disant ça
c'est des attrape touriste ou cdc des
bêtises pour les enfants c'est une bête
mais ça permet de se rassurer aussi de
se remettre parfaitement dans l'état
d'adultes c'est très rassurant ça et
l'autre manière c'est à dire d'y croire
dur comme fer au feu à tout ça et d'une
manière un petit peu un petit peu
premier degré quoi pour moi c'est deux
choses là s'échapper à la profondeur des
choses à la profondeur de cette lune et
toutes ces légendes là toute cette
littérature parce que nous parle d'abord
de littérature orale et écrite
elle a une vraie profondeur si des
générations et des générations de deux
parents de grands-parents d'écrivains
d'artistes et d'enfants d'ailleurs et
d'adultes sont donné la peine de
transmettre ces histoires-là de de les
travailler de les inventer d'ailleurs de
les travailler de les retravailler ses
qui l ont bien quelque chose à nous dire
[Musique]
nous survolons actuellement les forges
de paimpont situé proche du village de
plélan-le-grand en bordure d'un étang de
plus de 10 hectares appelé l'étang du
pont du secret
[Musique]
les forges de paimpont c'est un ancien
site industriel classé monument
historique est actuellement en
restauration
[Musique]
durant trois siècles ce fut le siège
d'une formidable aventure industrielle
c'est en 1633 que le duc de trémouilles
obtient l'autorisation de créer une
forge au sein du plus grand massif
forestier de bretagne le minerai de fer
hématite rouge est extrait proche de
l'étang
le charbon de bois est extrait des
forêts proches le réseau hydraulique est
aménagé entre les différents et en
ruisseau en 1853 les forges atteignent
leur apogée en termes de modernisme et
de production fournisseurs de l'arsenal
de brest de l'arsenal d'artillerie dren
et producteur de rails de chemin de fer
la concurrence étrangère le manque de
compétitivité mettrons fin
définitivement à l'âge d'or de ses
forges en 1884 de cette époque
subsistent
le village des formes avec six hauts
fourneaux le laminoir l'ancienne
chapelle et la maison du maître des
forges
[Musique]
tréhorenteuc est un petit village situé
au bord de la forêt de brocéliande non
loin du val sans retour tréhorenteuc
signifie pays de la charité car il était
jadis un centre de distribution d'eau
moon dans les années 630 saint onen
soeur du roi judicaël regardais les oies
en signe d'humilité
la première église de tréhorenteuc est
construite au septième siècle
dès 1942
l'abbé gillard recteur de tréhorenteuc
la restaure et la transforme en temple
du graal
les travaux dureront 12 ans l'abbé
gilles à recréer un univers joyeux roman
de la table ronde en visitant cette
église ont fait un voyage dans le mythe
arthurien dans la religion chrétienne
mais aussi en nous la porte est en
chacun de nous et c'est à nous de la
trouver cette phrase de l'abbé gillard
explique bien les itinéraires mythologie
pain dans cette église
elle nous invite à aller bien au delà du
visible et a entamé sa propre quête la
baie zellers et un prêtre c'est le
prêtre qu'areva très lente qu'en 1942
déjà ses textes centre et les chemins et
les routes n'existent pas sont des
chemins et en plus dieu si on est en
pleine guerre donc il ya des moments
plus facile la bg leur arrive là c'est
la première paroisse dont il a la charge
c'est un homme qui a déjà 42 ans et qui
est regardée avec un petit peu de
suspicion par l'autorité ecclésiastique
parce que il a déjà des centres
d'intérêt qui sont un petit peu de
déviance pour un prêtre qui
s'intéressent à l'art la symbolique au
tarot au zodiac mais c'est en même temps
un prêtre très très imprégné de son rôle
et de son de sa mission de de conduire
un troupeau de fidèles et de la paix de
le mener là où il faut il arrive dans
cette église de trenton qui est en ruine
avec une paroisse qui est on est rouge à
tréhorenteuc couleurs dès l'époque on
disait pas des communistes disons nez
rouge des terres rouges à tréhorenteuc
dont plus personne ou presque on allait
à l'église et il prend tout ça en main
et reconstruit tout le bâtiment et la
communauté des fidèles et il va
découvrir brocéliande et sa légende et
il va se faire pour lui une fusion une
fusion absolument étonnant qu en ce sens
que le langage de l'évangile qui est
celui que dit son église et le langage
que raconte que disent les rom arthurien
quelque part c'est la même chose et il
s'installe en dix ans la fois nié une
quelconque soit donc moi je suis là en
ce moment mais je suis l'héritier de
ceux qui avant moi ont porté ici une
autre fois donc ils se placent en
héritier des druides en hériter des
moines
il ya un âge et en curé du 20e siècle et
tout son église il va la décorer avec il
n'y a pas une pierre il n'y a pas un
dessin il n'y a pas une sculpture qui
toi pas un message pour donner les clés
des mystères du monde des symboles du
monde les clés de l'harmonie la liaison
entre le entre le monde celtique la
religion celtique et le monde et la
religion chrétienne comme il est
extrêmement pauvre et que c'est pas une
commune comme tréhorenteuc qui riche et
bien il entre en quête et enquête à tous
les sens du mot qui demandent de
l'argent et il vend demandé partout pour
embellir dans le seul but de faire de ce
sanctuaire de tréhorenteuc un sanctuaire
unique à la gloire bien sûr du christ à
la gloire de l'ancien religion celtique
à la gloire dé légende du roi arthur et
surtout célébrant le graal et il va
réussir donc entre 42 et 53 à trouver
des mécènes à trouver des artistes de
bonne volonté et l'histoire la plus
connue c'est bien entendu à la fin de la
guerre quand il va chercher deux
prisonniers allemands dans un camp à
rennes et il demande à l'officier qui
commande le camp de bien vouloir lui
confier un peintre et un menuisier et ce
peintre là va perdre sous la dictée il
écrit à sa femme qui reste à la manille
moi je n'y connais rien ces histoires là
c'est monsieur le curé qui me dit ce
qu'il faut faire et je fais tout ce que
me dit monsieur le curé et dans un
dernier mouvement qui est très étonnant
non seulement le curé fait peindre tout
ça mais il va continuer l'amalgamme et
même l'histoire même la passion du
christ même les le chemin de croix va
s'inscrire non pas dans un peu ce
paysage pseudo moyen orientale comme
c'est très généralement la tradition
depuis depuis des siècles des siècles
non ça va être dans le paysage de
tréhorenteuc dire qu'on va reconnaître
la porte du manoir la porte de l'église
les rochers comme le rocher le
le siège de merlin on va retrouver tout
ça dans le monde de plus ces fameux
grand tableau donc de lancelot le
tableau des chevaliers de la table ronde
et puis et puis la station qui fait
gémir et hurler les bien pensants c'est
à dire que le jésus tombes écrasés par
nos péchés et tombe plusieurs fois et
une fois il tombe au pied d'une
pécheresse qui est une personne ac
cambrai légèrement vêtues du voile rouge
une figuration assez assez naïve en fait
et tout le monde spontanément dit le
péché le péché de chair on ne peut pas
penser à autre chose mais là la tenue de
la dda le péché de chair c'est forcément
marie madeleine non c'est la fée morgane
puisqu'on et on a tout replacer dans la
légende arthurienne morgan la somme la
plus luxurieuse de son temps 10 et les
romans l'abbé gillard et inter la femme
luxurieuse comme la luxure pêchait sur
lequel devant lequel s'écroule le christ
et il ya cette espèce de fusion complète
et l'abbé gilles arva va jusqu'en 1900
69 va s'occuper de son église parce
qu'il a aussi dans la tête
le l'avenir de ses fidèles le devenir de
ses fidèles et il sait que c'est une
région pauvre il sait que c'est une
région sans beaucoup de moyens et il
voit aussi que le tourisme peut aider
ces gens à vivre et ils sont bien toute
la portée qu'il y a dans cette idée de
brocéliande en cette idée diligente donc
il faire danser tout ça à la fois
sauf que la hiérarchie catholique est
peut-être moins enthousiaste que lui et
il est quand même en butte à un certain
nombre de critiques voire de
tracasseries tant et si bien qu'un jour
ils abandonnent très honteux qui est
libre je pars à paris je vais me
consacrer à une mission là au moins je
serai utile mais on ne l'attend pas à
paris personne au delà de l'accueil
et quand il revient à tréhorenteuc on
lui dit vous êtes parti maintenant c'est
fini mais il prend l'habitude petit à
petit de revenir le dimanche ils étaient
là dans son église avec son bateau et il
expliqué tous les symboles dont il avait
chargé surchargé chaque chaque tableau
est que cet homme s'est brûlé dans cette
histoire ce prêtre ne s'est pas remis de
cette aventure mais a laissé quelque
chose d'unique
il faut voir l'église 35 mais je trouve
qu'il faut plus la voir au travers de la
belle aventure de l'abbé gillard
aventure unique que comme un lieu
symbolique parce qu'après tout des lieux
symboliques n'importe quelle grande
cathédrale il beaucoup plus de choses
à
c'est un grand cave au néolithique fermé
on y voit deux gros blocs de pierre de
schiste rouge de quatre mètres 5 de long
et d'un mètre de haut
les fouilles du tombeau menée en 1982
par l'archéologue jacques briard révèle
plusieurs occupations humaines entre
3000 et 1500 avant jésus-christ il
s'agissait probablement d'un alignement
de 4 mégalithes réemployer comme dalles
d'un tombeau la légende raconte que ce
serait le tombeau d'un géant mise à mort
par les chevaliers de la table ronde
toujours situé au coeur des légendes
arthuriennes nous voici dans la commune
de campénéac à l'ouest de la croix lucas
sur un site que l'on appelle le tombeau
des géants autrement appelée rocha la
vieille roche à la sorcière deux blocs
néolithique sépulture de l'âge de bronze
quatre mètres cinquante de long 1 m de
large pour la belle histoire
on raconte que ce sont les chevaliers de
la table ronde qui affrontèrent ici
les géants et les 20 tirs authier ou
hôtels en gallo signifie maison
lautié de viviane est située au
sud-ouest de la forêt de paimpont au
dessus du val sans retour
cette sépulture mégalithique culmine à
191 mètres d'altitude
elle est composée de onze dalle
d'environ 12 mètres de diamètre elle
daterait de 2500 à 3000 ans avant notre
ère
le pied de viviane à la forme d'un
coffre construit sur du schiste purpan
comme la plupart des monuments
mégalithiques de brocéliande
c'est un endroit mystérieux exigu pour
un lieu de vie la vue est très dégagée
et offre un bel horizon sur la forêt
la légende dit que viviane née dans la
forêt de brocéliande s'était fait
construire ce refuge pour échapper à la
vie de palets de son père joe jonas
c'est là aussi qu'elle rencontrait
merlin qui était tombé éperdument
amoureux d'elle avant que celui-ci lui
construise un palais de verre caché sous
le lac deux compères nous arrivons sur
le site appelé jardin aux moines dans le
village de néant sur yvel c'est un
tertre néolithique de forme poids de la
terre d'environ 25 mètres de long et 5
mètres de large
datant des années 3000 à 2005 avant
notre ère c'est un monument original et
sa fonction exacte reste un mystère
on peut y voir malgré tout une fonction
religieuse au rituel
la légende dit qu autrefois les
seigneurs et les moines avaient
l'habitude de mener mauvaise vie dans
des lieux très retirer de la forêt un
jour cinq semaines un prêtre du village
voisin
les surpris dans leur vie de débauche
et les incite à aussitôt à se confesser
pour expier tous leurs péchés
rien n'y fit moine des seigneurs
continuèrent à festoyer cinq semaines
les supplia de mener une vie plus
monastique
mais en vain la punition divine ne se
fit pas attendre un énorme orage éclata
moines des seigneurs furent transformés
en blocs de pierre sur le lieu même de
l'or gris pâle les tables des bancs et
ont maintenant disparu
seuls 27 blog du côté nord et 26 du côté
suis alterne quartz et schiste rouge qui
est l'un qui est l'autre lune 17
à
la forêt de paimpont renferme de très
vieux a le plus célèbre d'entre eux est
un vieux chêne appelé le chêne à
guillaume n'est situé entre les villages
de concoret et de tréhorenteuc on lui
donne environ 1000 ans d'âge c'est un
chêne pédonculé de près de 20 mètres de
haut et de près de 10 m de circonférence
une histoire raconte qu'à la fin du
xviiie siècle un prêtre réfractaire
nommé l'abbé guillotin pourchassé par
les sans culottes se cache dans le tronc
creux de sept ans les soldats sous ce ne
s'approche du chêne mais c'est alors que
notre dame de paimpont se transforme en
araignée et s'empresse de tisser une
toile devant l'orifice du cher les
soldats s'éloigne alors sans découvrir
la baie
l'abbé guillotin attendit quelques jours
avant de sortir le temps que l'armée se
dispersent dans la campagne
la vieille écorces de ce chêne marqué
par le temps pourrait nous raconter
encore bien d'autres histoires et chaque
année le majestueux reverdy et nous
laisse admirer sa grâce
[Musique]
nous survolons actuellement un des plus
beaux châteaux de la forêt de
brocéliande le château de tracy sont les
situé tout près de la commune de
campénéac et son origine remonte au 15e
siècle construit en schiste rougeâtre il
a gardé son aspect médiéval de
nombreuses légendes hante les lieux et
la plus célèbre est celle de la dame
blanche de trécesson c'est vrai aussi
que les faits très souvent ont été
associés aux comores au défunt c'est
vrai si par exemple la banshee est une
fée mais c'est aussi un fantôme elle
vient annoncer les les morts elle est l
été les malheurs elle donc elle est
vêtue de blanc c'est la dame blanche qui
peut aussi parce qu'elle apparaît dans
les endroits
désolé près de ruines près de château
mais aussi dans des grottes près des
sources de dos
donc cette dame blanche apparaît et les
confondues au fait très souvent et faut
pas oublier aussi que les fait vivre
dans les tertres les lutteurs des faits
où il y avait des menhirs il
y avait les dolmens qui étaient des
lieux aussi funéraire l'apparition la
dame blanche
il y en a une très célèbre stade rennais
sont donc à bûcheron
un peu braconniers
reviens de d'avoir été chassés relevé
s'est collé une charrette arrive est ce
que c'est une charrette parce que c'est
peut-être aussi la carie colobane coup
c'était là la charrette de l'anc ou de
la mort donc il se cache dans le buisson
il a un peu peur
hervé sakharov d'un carrosse qui arrive
un riche carrosse et donc il se tassent
encore parce que si on on lui demande ce
qu'il fait là il a quand même été relevé
décoller et le carrosse s'arrête et des
gens bien vêtu redescendre des
gentilhommes avec le chapeau en panache
et de belles tenues ils sont masqués
sont encapuchonnés ils ont de grandes
capes et ils vont descendre une jeune
fille vêtue en mariée vêtue toute
blanche très belle et elle semble dormir
elle semble flotter dans entre deux
mondes et ils vont la d2 va creuser un
trou et on va l'enterrer vivante dans
cette tombe et le carrosse va partir va
s'en aller comme ça dans l'allée et le
braconnier donc effrayer affolé va
courir au village en vitesse ameuter les
voisins dire voilà voilà ce que j'ai vu
que tous vont revenir sur place vont
déterrer la jeune fille il est trop tard
elle est morte mais on n'aura jamais su
qui était ces personnages qui sont venus
et pourquoi il ya un mystère autour mais
toujours est il qu'elle réapparaît
encore et la robe blanche de cette dame
blanche est toujours dans la forme dans
le dans la forêt de trécesson mais aussi
dans le château de trécesson qui a un
aspect assez rébarbatif à ces sinistres
qui est qui qui qui est très film
gothique et ça c'est aussi un des
aspects de brocéliande
c'est ce côté riant ce côté attirant
mais toujours comme les belle ténébreuse
qui vous attire pour mieux vous
vous entraîner au fond des abysses dont
on ne ressort jamais
[Musique]
donc le créateur de sa superbe décide de
faire un fils on le connaît il a mal
fini hélas ce sur la croix mais le
lucifer le diable les forces ténébreuses
ou tout au moins trop naturelle trop
païenne décide aussi d'avoir un fils il
est jaloux on se dit quand même là le
messie arrive moi je n'ai rien donc il
va décider d'avoir un fils il veut un
fils il veut un fils il veut un
descendant sur terre un qui puisse aussi
amener sa parole à lui et il va choisir
auprès de plusieurs auteurs
une jeune fille très jolie fraîche jeune
fille hélas très pieuse et l'âge du bien
hélas pour ce qui va se passer c'est à
dire que il aimerait donc lui le prince
des ténèbres le roi des ténèbres amené
le chaos sur terre et non il va choisir
une sainte et là elle va devenir mère et
elle vend gendre est un personnage
étrange cural est la puissance du diable
mais qui aura hérité par contre de la
pureté de sa mère qui aura la lumière de
sa mère qui aura l'innocence de sa mère
ce sera merlin ce sera un enchanteur le
diable va vouloir envoyer sur terre une
créature chaotique ténébreuse etc
mais comme elle sera toujours innocente
le jour et le centre parce qu'il ya
toujours l'intérim et diers une mortelle
qui sera une espèce de belles dormantes
qui reçoit et 7 et ça représente tout à
fait le paganisme
c'est dire qu'ils ne sont ni bons ni
mauvais merlin nenni
bon ni mauvais il a fait alliance avec
la nature la nature n'est ni bonne ni
mauvaise elle est la nature elle se
savoir que qu'on a aussi en nous qu'on
oublie un petit peu c'est à dire le
savoir de d'une prescience d'une
inconscience très fort de l'instinct de
la nature celui qui comprend les animaux
très souvent dans les comptes on dit il
était une fois au temps où les bêtes
parler les bêtes ne parlait pas on
comprenait leur langage on parler le
même langage que les animaux aient
merlas lorsqu'il va naître
il connaîtra ce langage des animaux il a
fait alliance avec la nature et donc le
merlin va arriver avec ses ces dons que
lui a offert le diable mais qu a adouci
cette mère qui est toute innocence et ça
va être le règne de merlin et merlin
évidemment on va connaître plein plein
aventure
[Musique]
le tombeau de merlin se situe au nord de
la forêt de brocéliande dans un endroit
appelé les landes elle aujourd'hui il ne
reste que des vestiges de se promener
trois dalles de schiste rouge à dos et
offre de nombreux visiteurs viennent en
hommage aux grands chanteurs et ils y
déposent message offrandes et couronnes
de fleurs
et ce tombeau de merlin et est donc une
ancienne allée couverte qui a au moins
4000 ans qui est restée dans son jus
j'avais dire pendant très longtemps
jusqu'au moment où il y à quelques
siècles à peine le propriétaire des
lieux qui voulaient vérifier si la
légende était vrai la légende qui disait
que sous ces pierres là il y avait des
trésors et bien c'est toujours dangereux
de vouloir vérifier si les jantes soit
il a voulu vérifier si cette légende
était vrai et il a pris des bâtons de
dynamite et il a fait exploser le moment
tout simplement il n'a rien trouvé mais
il a perdu quelque chose il a perdu
l'intégralité du monument et voilà
pourquoi aujourd'hui on ne voit plus que
que ces deux pierres là qui vont être
rebaptisé seulement une tombeau de
merlin et je pense que si cette forêt
magique s'il ya toute une partie de la
forêt qui est magique c'est parce que
l'âme de merlin est toujours à
l'intérieur de cette forêt on montre le
tombeau de merlin
mais on ne sait pas trop où ils et
intérêts c'est vrai qu'il ya une tombe
c'est important d'avoir une tombe
d'avoir un rocher beau qu'on viennent se
recueillir pour qu'on vienne y puiser de
la force qu'on vienne y toucher le
rocher avec le ou planter dedans et puis
aussi qu'on y dépose des démarques de
son âge de sa venue
et puis des voeux des demandes mais il
est partout il est dans le vent il est
dans le parfum est dans le chant des
oiseaux
de temps en temps on peut l'apercevoir
même on voit une ombre verte se
profilait entre les arbres c'est merlin
la fontaine de barenton se situe à
l'ouest du hameau de la folle pensée des
mille cent soixante elle est mentionnée
comme fontaine pouvant déclencher des
orages la localisation n'arrive qu'en
1467 et ses 10 14 de laval seniors deux
compères qui désigne cette fontaine sous
le nom de barenton c'est une fontaine
miraculeuse qui marque l'imaginaire des
hommes à travers les âges une large
pierre sur laquelle quelques gouttes
d'eau versées peuvent déclencher les
oranje
il ya un autre lieu aussi incontournable
et quand je parle de l'incontournable
c'est incontournable parce qu'ils font
cours de quoi qu'on tournait toujours
contournées dans cette forêt de
brocéliande
ce père c'est la fontaine de barenton
cette fontaine est aujourd'hui si vous y
allez
si vous trouvez le chemin cette fontaine
est au centre de la forêt au sommet de
cette colline de brocéliande
c'est donc un point tout à fait central
est dominant cette fontaine est toujours
en haut elle fait toujours des bulles
alors on y allait déjà pour savoir si on
allait se marier les jeunes fille
partait le matin là encore il faut se
mettre dans le dans le climat de
l'époque mais qui est toujours possible
puisque le temps ne change pas ne bouge
pas donc on va le matin et si on va se
promener se mirait sur les hauts de la
fontaine de barenton de barenton caylar
justement où il y aura cette espèce
d'alliance et il va se passer quelque
chose de magique
si on jette des aiguilles dans cette
dans cette source
elle va rire peut-être et le rire de la
fontaine de barenton est magnifique
parce que ce sont des petites perles
d'eau qui viennent du tréfonds du secret
de la source de la fontaine du mystère
de
des abysses de la bible on sait pas trop
et va remonter en souriant en chantant
par des petites bulles des perles d'eau
qui vont naître à la surface de l'undd
et qui va aussi si on se penche se mêler
à notre reflet si on regarde bien on
pourra voir le portrait de celle qu'on
va aimer de celui qu'on va aimer et pour
le savoir on va jeter c'est un caillou
et si l'image s'efface si elle est
sombre si elle est gâchis si elle et
ternat ce n'est pas un bon un bon
présage
par contre si la lumière vient le
frapper c'est un très bon présage
et bien par anton c'est le seul lieu où
vous allez retrouver localement ici une
tradition ancienne attester d'une
fontaine qui a le pouvoir de faire la
pluie et chose que vous retrouvez trait
pour trait dans le texte de chrétien de
troyes écrit fin xiième siècle
ivins le chevalier au lion dont le
théâtre principal est la forêt de
brocéliande c'est d'ailleurs la première
occurrence du du môme du mot un gros c
lients d'une brousse en hollande dit
chrétien de troyes et brocéliande et la
forêt des enchantements la forêt dans
laquelle on peut trouver cette fontaine
et la forêt dans laquelle on peut passer
de l'épreuve de la fontaine c'est à dire
prendre la coupe qui dans l'arbre à côté
de la fontaine la plongée dans la
fontaine prendre deux autres cette
fontaine aspergé la pierre merveilleuse
qui est à côté et déclenché un orage
cataclysmique sur tout sur toute la
forêt qui fait fuir les animaux tomber
les feuilles des arbres et qui fait
aussi arrivé donc je vais aller voir les
états chevalier tempestaire et en
apparaissant il ya un coup de tonnerre
qui va ponctuer le le coup de sabot de
son cheval et l'orage va jaillir de de
la forêt le tonnerre la pluie va
s'abattre les nuages vont s'amonceler
noir opaque terrible sur les au dessus
des frondaisons et vous avez percés par
des hallebardes de pluie d'averses et là
il n'ya qu'à fuir
ir et même tout en tout temps vous
souvent à la pression que derrière une
armée de temps poster comme ça qui
crépite derrière et qui essaie de vous
happer et de vous noyer la fontaine de
barenton est la vraie source sacrée de
la forêt de brocéliande
la dalle est juste la fontaine est
appelé le père en 2001 elle scelle la
première rencontre le merlin et de
viviane c'est une fontaine qui détient
des pouvoirs magiques et jusqu'au milieu
du 19e siècle
elle a été le théâtre des cultes et des
dévotions les plus variés de nombreuses
générations clergé en tête se rendent en
procession à cet endroit pour implorer
la pluie durant les années de sécheresse
en 1931
on veut ouvrir un sanatorium et on
raconte aussi qu'à cet endroit
les druides ont construit un hôpital et
une école que les os les rivières les
fontaines
les lacs bénéficie de la présence
bénéfique d'un élément talent vous
diront certains d'une figure tutélaire
légendaire qui est une fée la dame de la
fontaine la dame du lac
celle de barenton elle s'appelle laudine
est là pour servir une autre vie qui
s'appelle lunettes essais dont claudine
qui décide et qui a besoin d'un champion
pour défendre pour défendre ce
sanctuaire alors autour de barenton il
ya d'autres traditions sa ans plus tard
c'est la première cette fontaine cette
fontaine de barenton dont l'eau ou alors
qu'elle est plus froide que le marbre
pour moi s'il fallait il veut raccourcir
est allé très vite on pourrait dire que
tout part de là et que tout y revient on
n'en a pas la preuve exact mais mais il
faut aussi avoir un peu de bon sens
c'est-à-dire qu'une fontaine
bouillonnante ça ne compte pas tout à
fait toutes les forêts quand on voit ces
bulles s'échapper du fond de la de la
fontaine est crevé à la surface
l'étonnement est toujours là donc dans
un monde où on est pétri de rationalisme
de tout ce que vous voulez de science
fiction et de cinéma ça fonctionne
encore
pour terminer comment ne pas citer ce
poète du 12e siècle
roberval lorsqu'il parle de la fontaine
de barenton j allais en rêvant rêveur
genre 20 et ce rêve rêveur me tiens
[Musique]
e
le val sans retour est une vallée
encaissée très contrastée par ses
paysages et creusé dans le schiste rouge
il est situé non loin du bourg de
tréhorenteuc le val sans retour porte
bien son nom
quatre kilomètres de sentiers rocailleux
en font le tour et le schiste rouge qui
la composent fausserait nos boussole cet
endroit doit son nom à la fée morgane
demi soeur du roi arthur
une des faits les plus connus et les
plus redoutés
[Musique]
là on va les lieux magiques que si la
forêt de brocéliande y en a on a
l'impression que chaque fois qu'on fait
un pas de plus on tombe dans un autre un
autre royaume de danse chante mans c'est
morgane donc on l'a toujours vu un peu
en train de traficoter avec des avec des
filtres magique avec des filtres secret
on en a fait vraiment une
une fée sont brunes fait noir a en fait
la malheureuse n'a jamais eu de deux
réussites amoureuse a toujours été même
et traille et morgane un jour tombe
amoureuse d'un jeune un jeune chevalier
et qui lui fait la cour et se laisse à
l'est cette vierge sont cette vierge
noire le seul essai en compte et et elle
va
aussi avoir ce son coeur qui va
s'attendrir et elle va être
passionnément amoureuse de ce chevalier
et 7
ce chevalier et bien valu mentir vas lui
mentir en fait au lieu d'aller voir sa
belle il va faire la cour à une des
suivantes de morgane
il va séduire 7,7 suivante elle y va
l'entraîner
tous deux vont s'en aller dans la forêt
pratt and is est aussi bon sens du terme
quoi ils vont se coucher dans l'herbe
apte et dans les fougères de fonnière et
morgane va les surprendre ce couple qui
l'a trahi son son hameau son chevalier
qui l'a trahie avec sa suivante
et là alors elle va leur jeter une
malédiction puisqu'il est ainsi c'est
ainsi et bien je vais me venger tous les
faux amants tous ceux qui ont donné un
faux serments ceux qui ont avoué un
amour une passion et qui l'a trahi
eh bien il chacun d'entre eux se verra
enfermé dans le val sans retour dans le
rocher
alors il y a sous ces rochers une
forteresse paraît-il avec des salles où
les chevaliers festoient comme ils
peuvent
tristement quand même mais ne peuvent
plus en sortir sains et ne peuvent plus
en sortir ils sont prisonniers
alors c'est garder aussi par des lions
par des dragons qui sont postés on peut
les entendre la nuit quelquefois on voit
des rougeoiement vers le soir
danser comme ça sur l'escaut les rochers
ce sont les les fourneaux de de cette
forteresse qui qui s'allument on entend
aussi grenier les les les dragons qui
gardent les entre elles et lyon qui
gardent les entrées et quelquefois on
peut entendre les chevaliers chanter
entre choquer leurs à naples heures le
revers chantonnay tristement quand même
parce que même s'il essaie d'être joyeux
ils sont prisonniers éternellement
prisonniers alors tous ceux qui sont
encore aujourd'hui si un touriste dit on
se promène par là il peut quelquefois ne
plus jamais sortir du val sans retour
mais tourner éternellement
quoique morgan dans sa grande générosité
quand même parce qu'elle n'était pas si
méchant que ça a dit voilà tous ces
chevaliers sont prisonniers à moi à
moins qu'un jour un vrai amoureux
passent par là et celui qui passera avec
le coeur pur
un choeur empreint d'un amour
extraordinaire où il n'y a nulle tâche
nul mensonge
un amour pur un amour passionnel éternel
celui là délivrera tous les chevaliers
prisonniers du val sans retour
prisonniers du rock prisonniers de cette
malédiction et un jour lancelot est
passée par là lancelot qui aimait
guenièvre qui ne jamais n'avait osé
avouer son amour à guenièvre qu'il
l'aimait cent-pour-cent affaires péché
de chair puisque il aimait autant son
roi sans s'usera le roi arthur que son
épouse guenièvre et bien été rester
chaste bon après ça s'est un petit peu
gâté mais enfin néanmoins lorsqu'il a
traversé ce val sans retour le péché
n'avait pas été encore commis et donc
son coeur pur de vrais amoureux à
délivrer les chevaliers du rock à
délivrer les chevaliers du maléfice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le val sans retour surplombe le miroir
au fait et on peut admirer ce lac tout
en descendant du val sans retour
[Musique]
alors si on continue le chemin encore si
on descend le long de cette pente du du
du vin sans retour on arrive au miroir
au fait le matin le soir
les faits viennent peignait leurs longs
cheveux au bord de l'eau et semi raid
ans dans les eaux alors ces taxes est
assez extraordinaire aussi et là encore
la réalité rejoint la le merveilleux
c'est qu'on peut voir leurs cheveux
on peut voir leurs cheveux fins longs
cheveux blonds enfin en automne vers le
début de l'automne vers le mois de
septembre
justement elles se parent elle se coiffe
pour leur dernière parade
c'est l'automne qui arrive et elle ont
dansé tout l'été elles ont des cédants
c'est tout printemps et maintenant il
est temps de rentrer dans le dans leur
château de cristal dans leur château
divers et qu'est ce qu'on voit dans
l'eau qu'est ce qu'on voit nue surnagé
sur l'eau les fils en dhr ok ce sigle
défilante ce sont les fils de la vierge
ce sont les fils as c'est le coton notre
dame
ces sondes et je teins qu'on appelle
aussi c'est à dire ce sont ces fameuses
petites araignées qui ne disent pas de
toile mais qui s'envolent comme ça
accroché un fil à un fil ténu un fil
très léger et ses fils de la vierge ses
fils de fait on les voit souvent sur les
fils de fer barbelés on les voit le le
matin scintiller avec la la brume
derrière on les voit argenté ses fils
argentés et on dit que ce sont les
cheveux défaits et d'ailleurs quand tu
as un de ses fils se pose sur votre
épaule
c'est qu'une fée pense à vous ou qu'une
fée vous protège et comme c'est en
septembre qu'elles apparaissent
et comme ces temps au mois de septembre
aussi que les faits se coiffe une
dernière fois on voit leurs cheveux
confondues au fil en dhr à ce que ce
sont des fils en dhr et ce sont les
cheveux défaits
on ne sait pas mais toujours est il
qu'ils sont là et scintille sur l'eau
donc si on boit aussi une petite goutte
une toute petite goutte de
de cette eau est bien on aura une
connaissance on a une connaissance des
faits du secret des faits de leurs
breuvages mais il breuvage secret pour
se faire aimer
pour voir des choses et aussi si on
prend un petit peu d'eau est consommée
sur les paupières
on pourra aussi peut-être voir une
petite fée s'enfuir ou on pourra voir
leur palais on pourra voir le ronde qui
s'en va vraiment dans les brumes de
l'automne pour rejoindre leur leur
palais du côté du château de comper
l'arbre d'or se situe sur la commune de
tréhorenteuc au bout de la digue du
miroir au fait et au milieu d'une
végétation dense et naturel alors
lorsqu'on rentre dans brocéliande
lorsqu on en sort si on en sort il y a
toujours une borne qui montrait la
limite entre ce monde et l'autre et en
brocéliande
il y a l'arbre d'or alors c'est une
création
nouvelle mais elle est déjà entré dans
la légende
à preuve c'est qu'on se souvient pas moi
je me souviens même plus de 2 de
l'auteur du sculpteur qui lag la craie
parce que lui même on a l'impression
qu'il est rentré dans la légende
il ya quelque chose que ma comme du
merlin l'enchanteur là dedans on a
l'impression qu'elle a jailli c'est de
cette souche comme ça mais en fait elle
a une histoire c'est qu'il n'y ait eu un
grand incendie
quelqu'un est mis le feu à la forêt de
brocéliande la forêt d'orient c'est
extraordinaire parce que on à renard l'a
brûlé on l'a éventré on la découpe et on
l'asphalté et elle renaît toujours de
ses cendres et là il ya eu un grand
incendie
il y avait une grande désolation sur ce
sol noir mais déjà il y avait la
renaissance il y avait des dd pouce de
d'arbres des bourgeons de l'herbe qui
pointait déjà mais d'un verre
extraordinaire d'un vert plus vers
encore que le lierre ne le vert
d'éternité qui poussait qui
rejaillissait et on a l'impression que
cette forêt est toujours dans une espèce
de renaissance même lorsqu'elle semble
mourir lorsqu'elle elle semble avoir été
oublié eh bien elle renaît il ya
toujours une renaissance
merlin est toujours là le feu du dragon
est toujours là on a l'impression que
c'est berlin qui de ses cendres de la
forêt brûlée pétrifiait inspiré
peut-être aussi ce cet artiste pour
faire cet arbre d'heure qui sort comme
ça de la callas du rock et qui va créer
un arbre qui est une espèce de
passerelles de lien entre les forces
célestes aérienne les forces stonienne
le terrestre
regardez cette cet homme c'est comme une
espèce de mirage c'est comme une espèce
de reflets de 2h d'heure qui vient
encore re naître et renaître et chaque
fois qu'on passe devant devant cet arbre
on emporte avec soi une petite parcelle
de la lumière de brocéliande et on le
sait que
la visite donc au au monde magique au
monde enchanté peut durer une éternité
si on n'y a donné son âme et biens en
retour on a aussi l'âme de brocéliande
on en met une petite parcelle une étoile
qui reste en soit jamais le temps d'un
battement de paupière comme le dit
pierre dubois
cette oeuvre qui pourrait paraître
décalé par rapport à l'environnement
magique de brocéliande
c'est naturellement intégré à l'histoire
et à la légende des lieux en septembre
1990 durant cinq jeux un violent
incendie détruit le val sans retour et
les landes voisines
à la demande de l'association de
sauvegarde du val sans retour et en
mémoire de ces événements
l'artiste sculpteur françois davin créé
et l'arbre d'or
c'est un immense trop de châtaignier
calciné recouvert de feuilles d'or 90
grammes est entouré de cinq chaînes
calcinés
cela représente le symbole de la
renaissance après la mort l'arbre d'or
fut inauguré le 10 août 1991
l'arbre d'or est une nouvelle légende la
forme des branches représentent les bois
et la tête d'un cerf animal mythique de
la forêt symbolisant merlin qui aimait
se transformer en serre quant au sein
chen calcinés selon l'abbé henri gila il
représente l'humilité face à la
toute-puissance du chiffre 1 alors il
faut se mettre aussi dans le dans le
dans la peau d'aider des gens d'héberger
des des boîtiers des bûcherons des
paysans qui devait traverser cette lande
autrefois autant d il était une fois au
temps des veillées et le moderne
aujourd'hui a perdu contact avec la
nature
mais lorsqu'il se retrouve à cet endroit
là il a à nouveau peur il retrouve sa
mémoire reptilienne cette mémoire
collective qui est en lui et là les
monstres réapparaissent les hantises
réapparaissent et 7 n'importe qui un
touriste lorsqu'il franchit le seuil de
cette lande bretonne de cette lande de
brocéliande
il va se retrouver dans ce dans ce
paysan moyenâgeux où dans ce
dans ce berger du 19e siècle qui va
traverser cette lande et là il y à des
interdits il y a le berger a le berger
de la nuit qui lui dit attention le jour
appartient mais la nuit m'appartient
lalande la nuit est à nouveau à moi que
viens tu faire ici tu es un haut revenu
et là il peut être dévorés par les
korrigans alors les korrigans c'est les
petits êtres bossu c'est des petits
êtres de la pierre et lorsque le
korrigan on vient le déranger dansez
dansez kern dans ces pierres dans ses
pires levée dans ses dolmens et menhirs
il peut être très dangereux alors pour
se défendre contre contre les mauvais
esprits lorsqu'on traverse la lande
il faut toujours avoir un bradage on ou
de jeunes et cons mais soit en
boutonnière ou à son chapeau pourquoi
par l'âge on est bien parce que
autrefois donc le diable les esprits du
mal les esprits du chaos l'esprit des
ténèbres profité de l'hiver pour
attraper les âmes qui traversaient les
landes et pour les entraîner en enfer
dieu dans sa grande bonté ali puisque
c'est ainsi je vais vous protéger le
lalande sera toujours fleurie elle ne
connaîtra pas les ténèbres
elle connaîtra pas justement cette ce
côté désertique
lorsque l'agent la fleur d'or de l'ajonc
fanera le jeune et va le remplacer
et lorsque le jeune est fan rats il y
aura à nouveau l'agent et dans les
genêts et dans les agents dans la petite
fleur de genêt et d'agents il y a
toujours une petite fée qui sommeille où
l'âme d'un défunt donc on est protégé
par ses défunts et on est protégé par
les faits
bannon les lutins c'est effectivement
difficile à voir les géants les ogres
les dragons les faits le graal excalibur
les châteaux de cristal qui apparaissent
et qui disparaissent
c'est du sur elle ça n'en porte pas le
nom parce que c'est charriées par une
tradition patrimoniale littéraire très
ancienne que l'on renvoie d'ailleurs
systématiquement du côté où de
d'élucubrations mystique de breton
invétérés ou ou du côté de contes pour
enfants c'est de faire comme si se dit
croire quand même et puis de dépasser la
la réalité l'imaginaire ne se pose pas
l'imaginaire c'est un autre chemin pour
comprendre le réel aussi ça n'est pas
d'un côté ce qui est vrai et d'un côté
ce qui est imaginaire non l'imaginaire
n'est pas le mensonge c'est c'est une
autre manière d'aborder les choses une
autre une manière poétique d'envisager
les choses
moi je pense qu'il faut des endroits de
liberté comme ça avec brocéliande c'est
aussi un endroit de liberté à l'endroit
de gratuité j'allais vous dire mais
gratuité dans tous les sens pour le la
beauté du geste la beauté la gratuité de
aller se promener dans une forêt pouvait
passer une journée sans débourser un
centime
ici est habituellement des endroits
comme ça c'est devenu la grande forêt
enchantée maintenant dans le monde
qu'on le veuille ou non un parent par la
force des choses par aussi la force des
hommes toutes les forêts sont un peu
grosse et liant le petit bois derrière
chez vous quand vous étiez petit c'était
brocéliande et ce qui est intéressant
effectivement c'est de donner à voir
entendre à lire toutes les grandes
oeuvres qui ont été créées autour de la
légende depuis on va dire au moins
depuis le xiième siècle avec geoffroy de
motos des bus 12e et puis chrétien de
troyes
donc pour les oeuvres écrites en latin
pour geoffrey lomu tu écris temps en
français c'est l'invention du roman
ancien français pour chrétien de troyes
et marie de france
nous sommes encore là pour des oeuvres
en verre et puis au 13e 12e 13e la prose
qui va reprendre qui va reprendre la
suite avec un cycle gigantesque rappel
le lancelot graal donc la vulgate
également de des dizaines de milliers de
vers qui vont reprendre tout ces gens on
voit une énorme floraison d'histoire
arthurienne de romans arthuriens au
xiiie siècle dans toute l'europe des
traductions des adaptations en allemand
en catalan
en italien un peu plus tardivement alors
plus proche de nous il ya ensuite les
nouveaux les nouveaux nouvelles formes
d'expressions artistiques comme la bande
dessinées illustrations le cinéma bien
entendu les jeux vidéo pourquoi pas là
le dessin animé par exemple il faut
citer walt disney revient sur qui tout à
fait important dans la remise au goût du
jour de la légende arthurienne qui va
faire d'eux de merlin un personnage
connu dans le monde entier y as well i
stay il y en a bien d'autres
il a excalibur fait par la warner bros
aussi en dessin animé
il y en a d'autres bien plus proche de
nous on pourrait parler d'eux des
inspirations très proche de miyazaki le
créateur de mangas japonais des studios
ghibli qui se sont qui c'est assez
troublant pour de voir comment dans
certains dessins animés comme princesse
mononoké on est très proche d'eux les
inspirations des sources de la légende
arthurienne le cerf blanc
le sanglier tout ça tout ça est assez
troublant donc il ya une certaine
continuité même par delà les différents
continents
mais il ya de toute façon une certaine
parenté entre les mythologie japonaise
et des mythologies celtic est assez
troublante il ya aussi donc le cinéma je
vous disais bien entendu alors le film
peut-être le meilleur encore à ce jour
c'est excalibur de john boorman en tout
cas celui qui respecte le mieux la
légende alors c'est un film qui est un
petit peu un petit peu vieilli peut-être
mitia qui encore un souffle un souffle
qui vous porte et à certains raccourcis
heureusement parce que résumer en un peu
moins de deux heures
toute cette histoire c'était une gageure
pour le moins appris à la parodie mais
également les monty python
un sacré graal des monty python c'est
quand même là aussi un morceau de
bravoure par les monty python c'est
intéressant et terry gilliam en
particulier c'est intéressant parce que
ce sont des humoristes certes mais ce
sont aussi des intellectuels de haut vol
un rien n'est laissé au hasard
quand vous voyez le havre de sacré graal
or bien sûr c'est de la farce
mais il ya là tous les passages obligés
des romans arthuriens tels que votre
2ème 3ème le passage du pont la visite
au château des pucelles les jeunes
filles
tout cela est étudiée rien n'est laissé
au hasard
on pourrait citer je vous le disais
beaucoup de filles adultes domaine
français est intéressant eric rohmer va
livrer un perceval avec fabrice luchini
premier rôle d'ailleurs de fabrice
luchini
c'est un film qui vaut le détour avec
les textes originaux chrestien-de-troyes
bresson frein lancelot également a eu un
film hollywoodien avec richard gier
autour de lancelot avec des costumes et
des décors un peu discutable mais bon le
terrain des intérêts de ce film c'est
que c'est une des seules transposition
connaissent à l'écran de l'essentiel du
texte de chrétien de troyes
lansol j'avais de la charrette et puis à
aussi c'est une série télévisée comme
camelot on peut dire c'est la dernière
grande oeuvre en date même si là on a
aussi du côté de la la parodie
c'est intéressant là aussi de voir que
astier sa famille se sont peut-être
saisie de cette légende au début comme
il aurait pu saisir d'autres choses et
puis on voit au fur et à mesure de leur
progression ne fut en mesure de saison
comment ils vont être pris à leur propre
jeu et comment ils vont finir par
comprendre l'importance de la légende et
comment la légende elle même pas
travailler leurs oeuvres parlons de
peut-être deux l'oeuvre emblématique de
notre modernité qui est la guerre des
étoiles star wars
voilà vous avez vous diront les temps
qu'ils arrêtent ce qui commence à avoir
de la légende arthurienne par tout ça
n'est pas moi qui le dit c'est george
lucas ce premier chef qui le dit quand
on leur a posé la question quel était
leur première source d'inspiration
procréer l'a77 oeuvre extraordinaire la
guerre des étoiles
lukas a répondu que c'était légende du
roi arthur et des chevaliers de la table
on part ça peut paraître un peu étrange
effectivement mais quand on s'y penche
d'un peu plus près on s'aperçoit que les
chevaliers jedi font écho aux anciens
chevaliers de la table ronde cet ordre
guerrier qui agit pour le bien
on s'aperçoit que obi wan kenobi
pourraient être des avatars d'un
certaine enchanteur de la légende
arthurienne yoda qui vit dans le monde
sauvage dans les marais qui va être le
conseiller du principe politique qui là
aussi est un personnage énigmatique du
côté du bien
bien sûr mais qui a une barbe une part
inconnu - pour ne pas dire une par une
par dhombres d'autres choses comme ça c
-b magique qui ne sont pas sans rappeler
excalibur le destin de luke skywalker
qui est tout à fait parallèle au destin
du roi arthur d'une illustre ascendance
mais qui seront pour être protégé
enlevés à leur naissance et élevé dans
un monde dans un endroit retiré du monde
comme disent les gens d'hollywood pour
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour faire un bon
film il faut trois choses la première
chose c'est une bonne histoire
la deuxième chose c'est une bonne
histoire explosive jeu c'est une bonne
histoire et cette histoire la légère
comme le monde cette histoire là ce sont
les grands récits structure que l'on
nous sommes passés depuis des milliers
d'années qu'on retrouvait dans les
assiettes dans cette mythologie qui vont
passer dans les contes et légendes et
qui vont arriver aujourd'hui au cinéma
tout cela n'est pas anciens antilles si
tout cela marche malgré le pied de
débauche d'effets spéciaux il à défaut
de la débauche de moyens c'est bien
parce que derrière ça il ya des ultras
mme archaïque anciennes
deux récits de récits très anciens moi
je vois des gens qui se promènent dans
la forêt et qui sont presque trop
d'ailleurs en tension parce qu'ils sont
abonnés ans donc ils veulent voir
quelque chose alors que c'est sans doute
le contraire il faut laisser la forêt
descendre en soit il faut les laisser
venir
il faut attendre qu'elle vous renvoie
ses odeurs ses couleurs ses lumières
il est une espèce de mise en condition
qu'ils aient comme celle-là la mise en
condition de la respiration méditation
ou deux il faut se laisser porter
ailleurs mais on sait quand même que
dans un lieu comme brocéliande
il y a cette possibilité là et puis je
crois qu'à brocéliande il se joue aussi
ce qu'il se joue on est très souvent
dans les sanctuaires dans les lieux de
culte
je fais partie de ceux qui croient qu'un
lieu de culte qui a beaucoup servi où on
a beaucoup prier ou on a beaucoup à
espérer
on a beaucoup pleuré aussi on a donné
des sentiments forts on a donné des
divinations aujourd'hui c'est un mot
pratique pourquoi pas et bien et on
reste quelque chose et à brocéliande on
retrouve tout ça est à brocéliande on
s'inscrit dans ce qu'il y à d'appel le
grand temps là qu'à ce moment là le
temps des druides le temps d
enchantement le temps des faits le temps
des romans est le nôtre ont un lien
commun on est sur le même sol une bonne
partie de la légende s'enracine en pays
celtiques en pays celtiques et que la
cornouaille le pays de galles et le sud
de l'ecosse sol et base avec la bretagne
armoricaine mais il ya sûrement plus de
choses dans la mise en forme initiale de
la légende au pays de galles c'est
évident par contre quand on lit les
romans canton les mêmes les skis ce qui
veut être de l'histoire au moyen âge et
qui n'en est pas vraiment on voit bien
que le lien avec l'armorique est
permanent et surtout l'histoire va faire
une entrée fracassante au 12ème siècle
au moment où les plantages mais vont
s'apercevoir que cette histoire du roi
arthur c'est quand même quelque chose de
très précieux et de très exploitable en
un temps où on
on ne peut être un grand roi on ne peut
être une grande dynastie quand se
revendiquant d'ancêtres très ancien et
très prestigieux et le roi d'angleterre
manque un peu de tout ça vu que
charlemagne est déjà bien pris en main
par la france et l'allemagne donc
l'angleterre est un peu en déficit et
les plantages inné qui sont pas du tout
des sept arrivées trouve la légende
celtique du roi arthur est là tout le
jeu pour eux ça va être de dire mais
c'est pas une légende
c'est de l'histoire c'est notre ancêtre
mais en fait avant ça on a déjà toute la
partie ni tic légendaire et folkloriques
qui s'est mise en place et qui elle est
commune à la frange ouest
deux des îles britanniques et à la
bretagne
un historien ne peut raisonner que sur
des documents sur des monuments sur des
actes or nous qu'est ce que nous avons
pour le remarquez rien des romans des
romans français des chroniques anglaise
dont on sait que la fiabilité est quand
même disons à remettre en cause
régulièrement mais un monument en loi en
actes qu on a rien là la grande
comparaison qu'on fait tout le temps
c'est charlemagne arthur parce que
charlemagne on a bien un corpus
légendaire absolument en arche rolland
qui font la montagne d'un coup d'épée on
à la barbe fleurie on a le géant de
jeunes c'est combien de mètres de haut
mais à côté de ça on a un tombeau avec
sa chapelle on a des lois on a des
palais on sait parfaitement ce qu'il
affirme à des batailles à la campagne
contre les sacs sont elles non non on
sait bien
arthur on a que le volant légendaire la
preuve les preuves accumulées se tuent
les unes des autres
parce quand on vous et lucide le même
personnage par quatre ou cinq solutions
différentes
vous dénoncez un chef de guerre celle du
vème siècle non c'était un chef de ces
deux gars c'était un homme un auxiliaire
de l'armée romaine venu de chez lessard
match au 4e siècle
oui parce qu'ils se battaient à cheval
et les sept n'avaient jamais vu de gens
se battre à cheval donc c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont fait les chevaliers de la
table ronde
le problème c'est que beaucoup de ceux
qui reconstitue fonctionne sur un petit
un petit élément et qu'on ne peut
prendre en compte la légende du roi
arthur que
si on intègre donc cette dimension
européenne sur l'intègre la littérature
si on intègre la comparaison des
religions et si on se dit voilà
l'histoire a ses règles et on les prend
et on n'en sort pas et à ce moment là
évidemment le matériau les deux comme
des et philippe walter qui est un grand
homme un grand spécialiste arturia il
faut bien reconnaître que le dossier
historique est désespérément vide
vous voyez la légende rien ne se perd
rien ne se crée tout se transforme
la légende continue pour pour le
meilleur et pour le pire elle passe
c'est aussi le propre du mythe d'être
d'être plastique et de pouvoir prêter le
flanc à différentes interprétations et
arthur charlemagne c'est un personnage
historique
donc voilà on ne peut pas les tendres ne
pas le faire voyager dans l'espace dans
le temps on peut pas le mettre au far
west c'est plus difficile voie arthur
oui et c'est comme une boule de neige
parce que plus vous en fait plus mouche
en fait c'est ça qui est tout à fait
intéressant et c'est ce que l'on dit
aussi c'est le sens de matière de
bretagne quelque part ça c'est parce que
les chercheurs avaient la matrice
comminatoire c'est à dire que vous avez
plusieurs objets vous avez plusieurs
lieux vous avez plusieurs personnages et
vous pouvez à l'envi infiniment ray
agrémenté tout ça en remettant un peu un
peu d'inspiration pour c'est un une
usine à créer des histoires en a
d'autres je ne dis pas que la légende
arthurienne est la seule il ya d'autres
magnifiques légende à travers le monde
c'est d'ailleurs peut-être un d une des
plus belles preuves de notre
l'humanité à tous la magie facile
surtout lorsqu'elle est associée à des
lieux légendaires et la forêt de
brocéliande en est un c'est un lieu
magique c'est le pays des faits c'est le
pays du prophète et enchanteur merlin
qui nourrit toujours notre littérature
depuis plus de mille ans les bretons
désigne cette forêt comme terre de
légendes et de mystère à l'orée d'un
bois sur les sentiers rocailleux au
coeur de la forêt d'aubépine au pied
d'arbres centenaires puissant et
majestueux derrière un rocher datant de
plus de 3000 ans aux abords d'un lac ou
d'un étang sur le perron de l'église du
graal à la découverte du diable qui
soutient la chaire de l'église de
campénéac autour d'une fontaine
jaillissante où se marient l'eau et le
feu devant les murs de pierre
rougissante d'achat tôt féodal tous ces
lieux nous séduisent et nous attire et
notre imaginaire se met en marche
ouvrons grand nos yeux et nos oreilles
savourons le calme et la douceur de la
forêt laissons-nous guider par nos
envies plongeon agréablement dans cet
univers de magie et de mystère
retrouvons le silence et le souffle de
la terre brocéliande histoire ou
légendes
[Musique]